un coup de pinceau assurer un regard
d'expert à plaisir claude briand a fait
de sa passion d'enfant son métier dans
son atelier il reproduit à l'identique
tous les modèles de voitures c'est
préférer ce sont les voitures de course
la période qui m'intéresse le plus c'est
les années 70 c'était une époque où les
voitures étaient déjà moderne mais ça
ressemblait encore à des voitures qui
n'étaient pas faites par des ordinateurs
claude briand est un artisan du modèle
réduit qui s'est formée tout seul depuis
40 ans qui travaille dans ce milieu ici
est fait un nom
le bouche à oreille fonctionne il
réalise des commandes sur demande
la première étape connaître un maximum
de détails pour réaliser son modèle pour
cela claude à ses archives
tout ça c'est une partie une partie de
ma documentation qui me sert à
travailler donc la gdd livres anciens
des revues de revues lacets sport auto
tout ça il ya des clients qui me
fournisse beaucoup de photos de leur
voiture donc je n'ai pas besoin de ça
mais il y en a qui ne fournissent pas
grand chose donc ça me permet d'avoir
toute la documentation sur sur les
détails de la voiture
le maquettiste fait lui-même le montage
de ses modèles il récupère les pièces au
gré de ses recherches ou ses clients lui
fournisse toutes les étapes sont
réalisés dans son atelier ici c'est la
cabine à peinture
c'est ici que je peins un montage coûte
entre 50 et 100 euros cela sans compter
les pièces un hobby onéreux mais les
passionnés ne fait pas j'ai toujours
aimé le sport automobile alors le sport
automobile bien plus que l'automobile
parce que pour moi l'automobile c'est
juste un moyen de transport
pas très commode et un peu onéreux par
contre le sport automobile ou et ça
c'est quelque chose qui me passionne
vraiment alors c'est une porsche 924 s
qui a été court si fier on va dire avait
été transformée en voiture de rallye je
les fait en miniature on dit toujours
que les cordonniers sont les plus mal
chaussés mais bon en l'occurrence j'ai
quand même fait ma voiture